isn't it necessary chris for a front man
to have a certain look
because when i watch the one of my
favorite videos to watch
when you're up there with paige and the
black crows
and you guys all toured together right
and you were singing led zeppelin that
is my
favorite concert to watch did it ever
cross your mind when you were working
with robert plant i mean when you were
working with jimmy page
i worked with robert too when i was a
kid in the first
it's funny when you talk about front men
like that
um in my case i would have probably been
a front boy
at this time but i opened for stephen
tyler and robert plant
within in the first five months of us
ever being a band
before black crows when you were no no
the black no we were the black crows but
that in 1990 like the first big tours we
did were opening for aerosmith and
robert plant
no kidding and i was like had to be
thrust out there with these like
famous like iconic you must have been
out of your mind with like glee working
around those guys would they hang with
you at all or were you just kind of like
you know um i guess it you know the
aerosmith
thing was really uh i mean stephen tyler
gave me my first harmonica
no kidding and i and taught me a little
how to blow a little bit have you ever
met somebody you worshipped and then you
suddenly go what the [ __ ]
no because i don't you know i don't ever
expect because you know who cares who
cares what i am or what i do
but i'll tell you the best you want to
know the best story warren haynes
this is 1990 first black crows were in
new york
the allman brothers are doing unplugged
right black crows had been on earlier
that day the guy from the show goes hey
you guys are from georgia you want to
come see the almond brothers like
yeah are you [ __ ] kidding [ __ ]
almonds so we go down there it's me and
my brother
rich rich and we sit there we're
standing there and warren
haynes like comes over and he's i've
never met warren and he's like
hey are you the two brothers from the
black crows and
we were like yeah you know he's like wow
i'm lauren and
we meet he's like i really like your
record and you know he's from north
carolina
blah blah blah as as we're talking
there's like a little room
and greg almonds in there like combing
his hair for like eight hours and blow
dragging
a lot of air and i was like jesus so
inevitably he gets up
and there's a small hallway and he has
to walk through the hallway to the other
room and we're standing there
yeah um and as he walks past this one
goes greg greg these are the this is the
black crows the two brothers from
georgia i told you about and he looks at
me and the corner
goes who gives a [ __ ] and he walked
faster you probably liked that i loved
it i mean if he'd stopped and said hey
great to me i wouldn't have a cool story
but it would have been funny too because
think about it i mean he and his brother
in a band and
the whole thing you know it was like it
was a similar kind of suggestion you
know they're from florida but they're
kind of came
together in georgia so but yeah he said
who gives a [ __ ] and you know it's funny
you know 27 years later who does i mean
really isn't that great when a guy
like just goes who gives a [ __ ] it was
great it's just so great
but then you didn't then the other stuff
happened in life like
you know the wondrous joe cocker you
know the first time i met joe was
right around that same time and we were
at the hotel lobby in los
angeles and i was i mean he's one of my
heroes and
there he is you know and i'm like oh my
god it's [ __ ] gentle
and he goes and he stands up in the bar
and he goes chris
and i'm looking around if someone is
chris christopher's in here or someone
famous i don't know he's like come here
and i go over and he goes oh my lad and
he gives me a big hug and he goes thank
you
thanks for keeping this music alive and
thanks for all the things you've said
about my band and my music
wow and ronnie lane the great ronnie
lane from the faces who had ms late in
his life
our very first shitty rock club gig
opening for some band in austin in 1990
and the guy from the club
we didn't even have a dressing room we
were like by the soda cans and all the
beer mutt stuff
and this guy says there's a guy in a
wheelchair out here
named ronnie lane who wants to see you
and my uh
and he came in and he was like oh just
want me a lot you know you've said so
much nice things about my music
and i want to see a real rock band again
you know those are the moments
and i was like yeah i'll remember that
forever the great ronnie lane the most
soul you know the great great ronnie
that was a great band
oh the best right you know so
there's you know those moments are also
the stuff and
you know i mean i people always you know
you're on the cover rolling stone i'm
like you know
i walked backstage at um in 1999 to see
crosby stills nation young and
every one of them said hello to me and
knew my name and i almost [ __ ] my pants
you